another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation dr bright is  no longer allowed to offer the solution  of use more guns to any problem dr  bright look at me we went over this  before with the chainsaws do you  remember we really need to do this again  i guess so we face a wide variety of  problems here at the foundation of  varying degrees of severity there's no  one-size-fits-all solution for these  problems and even if there was it would  not be use more guns or get bigger guns  this includes but is not limited to  old-fashioned dueling pistols machine  guns or something called the octogun  which my notes say were just eight guns  taped together how does that even work  never mind don't answer that the point  is it's not helpful and dr bright is not  allowed in the armory not even on his  birthday